un matériel ultra performant pour
examiner les momie vieille de 3000 ans
un étudiant a eu l'idée est d'utiliser
le scanner de l'hôpital de besançon pour
cette enquête à la fois médicale
historique
on n'est pas au bout de ses surprises
patrice playmate yes barrois des momies
de 3000 ans dans une ambulance c'était
jeudi dernier contre les transporte du
musée de besançon vers l'hôpital de la
ville
service radiologie c'est l'idée d'un
interne qui prépare une thèse passionnés
l'egypte ancienne
il a décidé d'examiner les momies avec
ce qu'il y a de mieux un scan sous les
bandelettes
voici donc l'un des défunts hang paquet
raid profession dessinateur dans le
grand temple d'amon à thèbes son âge 35
ans
premier bilan de santé assez positif
parce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il n'y
avait pas de tumeur osseuse de
métastases osseuses d'un cancer
quelconque c'est ramon a quand même
atteint un âge certain qui permet de
dire que quand même ils avaient un
niveau social qui lui permettait d'être
bien soignés bien soignées sauf les
dents avec de belles car y ait une
arthrose des genoux que l'on voit aussi
très bien mais le scanner a révélé un
autre secret de magnifiques amulettes
avait été placée sur le corps des momies
un babouin un oiseau un chacal et pour
finir une petite merveille près du coeur
un scarabée pour obtenir la vie
éternelle
c'est cette année cela représente
vraiment le coeur du défunt c'est une
des amulettes principal on va dire qu'on
retrouve sur les mobiles deux heures
plus tard tout est terminé
les momies regagnent leurs sarcophages
d'origine sur le bois finement pas
l'histoire de leur fille est racontée